where there are certain filmmakers that
you try to emulate your style like Roger
Corman who's known for Roger Angelique
women i should say they're known for
just doing things you know very very
quickly and being very cost efficient um
you know I i don't i don't have the the
background to know how filmmakers
actually have have done their films and
how efficiently they've done them life's
i basically had to reinvent the wheel
for myself so i didn't really have any
examples of the logistics of filmmaking
like how do we shoot a film quickly how
do we make a film in 21 days versus 45
days so these are experiences that I had
to sort of develop on my own you know
the only people that that you know once
again that that I emulated were just
sort of I guess you would call them kind
of dreams or fantasies but you like you
think of Sylvester Stallone for instance
you got a guy who comes in with a
screenplay and it says like look I'm
going to play this guy and you guys got
to produce it so those the type of guys
I think of or like you know Matt Damon
Ben Affleck they come up with a
beautiful screenplay and you know they
get at that time just Robin Williams who
was like super hot to do it and and it
gets sold and it moves forward or like
Vince Vaughn like I mentioned you know
they do a very relevant la centric film
so you know these guys are you know you
know in a whole whole different league
but you know that's who I kind of look
up to in regards to hoping to do a film
that you know will click you know at
some point um but the logistics of
filmmaking that's that's just been a
painful a learning process for me so I
kind of learned I figure out like what's
the most efficient way to do this like
the first film I did what I shot it on
35 millimeter so I did 35 millimeter I
looked at all the logistics of it like
then the telus inning the transfer how
do we get the film to the lab and then
the second film I was like wait a min
you know we got to go digital here
because we're going to be able to you
know really do a much better job so we
shot on the red so you know it's an
evolution and you become way
efficient as you start doing more and
more films and the current film working
on which is winters dream it's going to
be shot on a run to read this can be
shot in a red MX and an epic and so
we're going to be able to move a lot
more efficiently through scenes so as a
filmmaker you you at it's like anything
in life the more you do it the more
efficient you get the more better it's
just like practicing anything I think
you slowly get a little bit better at it
this time goes on
you